People love to dream...
...because dreams are awesome.
We dream at night and we dream during the day.
When we're young, we dream about what we wanna be when we're older.
And when we grow older, we dream about being young again.
In dreams, you can fly...
...and if you can't, you'll probably run into someone who can.
In dreams, you can go anywhere...
...like a distant land overrun by dinosaurs who sound like your good friend Carl.
Oh hey, what's up?
And even if these dreams become nightmares,...
...where all your teeth fall out and suddenly you're in school,...
...it's only a dream,...
...where your crush loves you anyway,...
...which is much better than being stuck on a bus with this guy.
So, if you could experience anything in a dream...
...just by putting a phone on your face,...
...why wouldn't you get that phone?
A new virtual reality powered Galaxy S7 Edge.